bonsoir
mais
et
quand j'ai débarqué dans le milieu de la
musique et quelques années maintenant je
connaissais absolument personne mais
j'ai eu la chance de croiser rapidement
des chanteurs que j'admirais et qui
m'ont tous aidé à un moment ou un autre
à devenir ce que je suis ici ce soir
c'est pour ça que j'aime à les appeler
mais les anges gardiens ob grand frère
le premier d'entre eux ce après daniel
darc ou souviens très bien du jour où je
les rencontre et parce que c'était le
jour où j'avais décidé d'arrêter la
musique j'avais créé mon projet solo
joseph d'anvers un peu plus d'un an
auparavant et j'envoyais mes mes
maquettes à différentes maisons de
disques et j'avais toujours à peu près
la même réponse
on adore ce que vous faites c'est
vachement bien mais on va pas vous
signez rappelez-nous dans six mois donc
au bout d'un moment j'ai commencé à
douter de moi et puis lentement à
désespérer pour atteindre quelque chose
dans le monde de la musique depuis un
jour d'avril et j'ai pris cette guitare
est gelée posé contre un mur et je me
suis dit que c'en était fini
j'étais pas fait pour ce pour ce métier
là alors je suis allé me balader dans la
rue
et puis rue rochechouart à paris là où
j'habite et je tombe sur daniel darc
j'arrive à vaincre ma timidité je
laborde et je lui ai dit tout le bien
que je pense de lui et ses chansons et
lille me regardent comme ça une bonne
gueule toi tu veux boire des bières
comme je refuse rarement ce genre de
proposition nous sommes allés boire
quelques bières on a refait le monde en
arabe parlé de musique on a parlé de la
ville on a parlé de littérature
américaine karukoski hemingway n'a parlé
de boxe un sport que je pratique est
depuis longtemps et puis on en arrive à
parler notre passion commune ce qui nous
anime est réellement l'un et l'autre à
savoir l'écriture je fais part de mes
doutes qui devait gros doutes
et lui il répond simplement il me dit tu
sais moi j'ai jamais été très très riche
et très célèbre j'ai même été très barré
dans la rue parfois mais j'ai toujours
été heureux parce que sur moi j'ai
toujours un un carnet et un stylo et dès
que je peux j'écris quand j'écris je
suis heureux n'oublie jamais ça et
ensuite il m'a
cette phrase célèbre celui qui n'est pas
prêt à mourir pour l'écriture ne devrait
jamais écrire je suis sorti de là
j'avais l'impression que le ciel était
plus bleue l'air plus vifs
j'ai l'impression que la vie était plus
belle et j'ai commencé à gamberger
quand je suis arrivée chez moi j'ai vu
cette guitare elle était toujours contre
le mur évidemment alors j'ai pris mon
carnet
j'ai pris mon stylo et je repris la
guitare ce jour là j'ai écrit une
chanson elle s'appelle les cicatrices et
c'est celle que je vais jouer maintenant
omer où êtes vous
à présent selon vous
qui sommes nous
des images calcinés
des rêves un peu abusé
des histoires oubliées
nos vies nos cicatrices
nos vertus et novices
le taux de qui s'immisce
et le tout qui s'immisce
là le
nous
là
omez anges où êtes vous
car j'ignore tout comme vous
ce qui reste après nous
et l'hommage que sont en jeu
à vivre par l'instinct
à le perdre finale
une
et on accuse le coup
et on reste debout ont faibli malgré
tout
lui
ophélie m'arrête là
là
comme un certain âge doit être vous
je suis perdu sans eau
je dois dire que pour
hb adhérer sans cesse on oublie les
promesses
en six heures des ans laisse s'envoler
les repères
nos idées réfractaires
et notre vie entier et l'autre des
antilles
là
oui
alors grâce à daniel darc non seulement
j'ai pas arrêté la musique mais en plus
quelques mois plus tard j'ai des signé
mon premier contrat en maison de disques
quelques mois plus tard encore j'allais
sortir mon premier album
le deuxième chanteur deuxième grand
frère qui a été important pour moi
s'appelait alain bashung j'étais en
pleine tournée promo de mon premier
album
quand j'ai entendu dire qu'alain
chercher des textes pour son nouvel
album qui allait devenir le pétrole
alors je lui ai spontanément envoyé
quelques textes et dès le lendemain
j'avais une réponse de son directeur
artistique qui me disait que alain avait
bien aimé ce qu'il avait lu qu'ils
voulaient me rencontrer l'après midi
même autour d'un café chez lui quelques
heures plus tard je me retrouve donc
j'ai bashung à boire des cafés et après
avoir fait un peu connaissance on se met
direct à travailler on attaque sur un
texte qui s'appelle tant de nuits et qui
finira donc sur bleu pétrole et au fur
et à mesure qu'on se met à travailler je
me rends compte qu alain mais distille
des conseils
il me donne des clés sur comment écrire
des textes composés sur comment être et
vivre tout simplement
mais jamais de manière frontale jamais
comme un prof ou comme un père toujours
de manière détournée bienveillante comme
un grand frère
et puis outre temps de nuit j'avais
aussi un autre texte qui lui plaisait
beaucoup qui s'appelait ma peau va te
plaire
et puis me demande si je me semble le
mettre en musique et puis je me senti
que moi je me sentais pas à l'époque
j'avais pas les épaules donc ils
essayent de lui de le composer quelque
chose dessus demande à d'autres et puis
il n'est jamais arrivé à quelque chose
qu'ils satisfassent donc on l'a laissée
de côté
et quand bleu pétrole est sorti alain
m'appelle pour me dire tout le bien
qu'ils pensent de notre chanson et me
dit souvient ma peau va te plaire
évidemment je me souvenais me dit
j'aimerais bien en faire quelque chose
j'aurais même que tu me garde le texte
devra même que ce soit le point de
départ du prochain album comme bashung
nous dit cela vous gardez précieusement
le texte ne touchait plus et puis
malheureusement comme la plupart d'entre
vous le savent
gare à jamais le prochain album d'alain
bashung donc au moment d'enregistrer mon
troisième album en 2010
j'ai repensé à tout ce que j'avais vécu
avec alain et puis j'ai repensé à ce
texte
alors je leur sortie et puis le dernier
jour d'enregistrement j'ai décidé
d'essayer de composer moi même quelque
chose et dans d'en faire une chanson
comme un hommage à ce grand monsieur qui
m'a ouvert tellement de portes qui a été
tellement bienveillant avec moi cette
chanson je voulais jouer maintenant elle
s'appelle ma peau va te plaire
je suis cette femme à qui l'on promet
rien je suis sûr qu'on croit pas par la
main je suis cette forme
qui ne vaut presque rien je suis cette
soirée qui s'est donné tu deviens
je suis est de faire
que tu regarde parfois je suis cette fin
actu ne cause pas je suis une femme
qui se blesse à chaque pas je suis cette
fin qui ne dort plus chez soi
serment encore
eh ben pour
te plaît
samba de terre
comme un semblant d'ordre
je suis cette fin
parce que bell regarde bien
je suis cette femme
faute de n'avoir plus
dont les hommes ont besoin
je suis cette fin
la maman la tute
et
c'est un mois encore
et maintenant
pas de pleurs
sans le thème
comme un semblant d'ordre
je suis cette femme
que le parquet a tué jeu si cette fin
aux milanais volée je suis cette femme
que les anges ou d'arrêt je veux juste
faire de la nuit pas aux manettes
servant encore
et ma peau
de pleurs
120 de terre
un semblant de rome
servent encore
la peau
va te plaît
sans voix le thème
un semblant de rome
les derniers grands frères dont je vais
parler ce soir
s'appelle mieux sec et 2 min k les
appels des grands frères déjà parce que
en fait c'est en écoutant leurs chansons
que quand j'étais ado j'ai commencé à la
guitare et c'est en écoutant aussi leurs
chansons que j'ai commencé à écrire les
premiers mots qui deviendront mes
premières phrases ils viendront mes
premières chansons
je sais que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer dès mon premier album il m'a
proposé spontanément de venir faire un
duo avec moi sur une de mes chansons et
quelques années plus tard n'a proposé de
faire ses premières parties sur une
trentaine de dates de medica j'avais
croisé au festival depuis sur des dates
communes on avait tout de suite
sympathisé le courant est tout de suite
passé et il savait que j'admirais son
travail et j'ai lu à travers la presse
que j'avais certaines de mes chansons
qui trouvait pas trop mal non plus et
puis à peu près un an et demi deux ans
je me suis mis à écrire et composer mon
nouvel album
celui qui est sorti à quelques mois et
puis je me retrouve sans maison de
disques à commun accord on met un terme
à notre relation est donc je me retrouve
tout seul pour faire cet album pour
l'écrire le proposer de produire le
réaliser et c'est dans ces moments là
ces moments de solitude et de doute
qu'on a des amis qui vous tourne le dos
et d'autres qui vous tendent la main
miossec des dominique à ont fait partie
de cette deuxième famille
quand ils ont été au courant de la
situation ils m'ont appelé tous les deux
genres expliqué un petit peu ce qui se
passait et puis ils m'ont dit l'un et
l'autre on peut pas faire grand chose
pour toi mais ce qu'on peut proposer
c'est que on va écrire un texte et tu va
le mettre en musique
alors 20 ans après après avoir été fan
de ces mecs là je me suis retrouvé à
faire une chanson avec miossec et une
autre avec dominique a et c'est cette
dernière que je vais vous jouez pour
finir cette intervention elle s'appelle
tremble merci beaucoup
nos pour joindre c'était facile et ses
membres présents la fumée
tu sur les champs
et les corps se cabre indocile c'est en
patins et vassy nos conjoints c'était
facile
et
tremble mon âme trop la terre des
fleurissements fumée montent sur les
champs des fissures lézardent de la
ville
tremble mon amour tu rends compte que
nos étreintes ce soir faut aussi que nos
regards
celui-ci simple battement de cils
nous rejoindre c'est est une heure ou
jouer avec tout le temps et le temps m
m
et la terre frais
maintenant ma soeur mon
tout le monde
noko jointe 7 et ina
tran que mon amour trop
frémissement fumée monter sur le champ
une fille sur les arts de la ville
tremble mon amour tu rends que nos
étraves ce soir voici que d'un regard on
se dit si un simple battement de cils
de pauvres gens qui ont voté là
pour ravitailler nos étreintes donner du
sens à deux plaintes
à nos gestes de m'atteindre mais la
fumée
de méchants logement convoité la main
tremble mon amour trop la terre des
frémissements l'affût mais bon
tout sur le champ des fissures lézardent
de la vie le tremble mon amour ont que
deux trains ont soif aussi que nos
regards
celui-ci simple battement de cils
merci beaucoup
bonsoir